[Music]
Jamie Diamond is the CEO of America's
largest and most successful Bank
JPMorgan Chase at the helm of a company
active in over 60 countries worldwide
Diamond played a pivotal role in the
global financial crisis of 2008 and
again in 2023
the economists editor-in-chief Danny
Minton bedos sat down with him to get
his take on the biggest financial and
geopolitical challenges facing the world
today do you think the world is more
dangerous than at any time in your
lifetime yes we haven't had something
like this since World War II and to
delve into his personal Ambitions for a
man who runs a very big successful Bank
you have a lot of ideas about public
policy why don't you run for office
Jamie Diamond thank you so much for
joining the economist you were in China
recently and reportedly you said that
the sino-us relationship was the most
complex since the second world war the
the geopolitics around that Henry
Kissinger I had a long conversation with
just a few weeks ago for his 100th
birthday and he said to us that he
thought that we were on the path to
great power confrontation yeah I mean we
should be talking to Chinese and they
should be talking to us I tell people
you go there the first thing should be
let's talk about your family
but then the next meeting maybe let's
talk about the hopes and aspirations for
your country and then the third meaning
is we're gonna explain what we're
worried about let's have a real
conversation this is going to take a
real tough negotiations to get it right
I'm a firm believer if you opened up our
borders billions of people would move
here
you know if you opened up our markets
trillions of dollars would move here
it's not true they move other to other
parts of the world so we should we
should be looking at our own flaws and
not always blaming other people the
Chinese are not 10 feet tall they they
import 10 million barrels of oil a day
they don't have enough food we have all
the foodborne energy we want our GDP of
person is eighty thousand dollars theirs
is 15. our military is the best in the
world you know and maybe they're caught
up in a couple areas but you know the
notion that somehow America has to be
that afraid of time we don't
on the other hand looking back 15 years
we all made a mistake we should have
been thinking this National Security
unfair competition and not just hoping
it'll end up okay they've been doing
that by 10 or 15 years if you look at
theirs how they think if it's Supply
chains Industries they want to dominate
they've been quite blunt about and which
I understand they're trying to do a good
job for their own country I was in
Beijing a couple of months ago you know
the view in Beijing is that the U.S
wants to keep China down and the view in
Washington is that China is a you know
aggressive authoritarian regime that
wants to create a world order that's
kind of antithetical to democracies
I think there's an element of Truth to
both of those and that's the problem
isn't it our goal should be to lift up
America do a great job keep our Western
alliances together both for the military
I.E Ukraine and to counter some of the
bad guys out there but economically we
need an economic comprehensive strategy
too that's trade investment you know
even like the IRA act which again I
support most of it it wasn't done really
thoughtfully with our allies who looked
at that and said that is the most
anti-european thing we've ever done and
you know sometimes they complain too
much but they're also partially right
and so to me we've got to keep that all
together and we can be tough and mature
and we don't have to hold them down we
have to protect ourselves and there's a
big difference between the two if one
side thinks the other is trying to keep
them down and frankly there is evidence
for that right I mean what are these
Expo controls on Advanced semiconductors
they're designed to ensure that China
stays far behind the US in the
cutting-edge Technologies of the 21st
century I think if it related to
National Security AI supersonic missiles
I understand why we do it if it relates
to holding back to Chinese people I
understand why you shouldn't do it so I
know I've had a couple of conversation
with people which about the two Nanos
the four Nanos the six Nanos where is it
being used in military equipment where
is it not being used you know no country
would give away their best military
equipment to another country that they
might go to war with so so that would be
okay it's just that's this narrow Garden
thing we have to be very careful about
and like I said I don't think we've ever
done this before so I think we're all
struggling to figure out what we
actually mean by that I think the
government is businesses are uh uh you
know but going and talking to each other
is the first way to say what really
matters what's important what protects
the United States what are the
geopolitical events other than China
which we've talked about that worry most
risks you know in 1918 we said never
again in 1945 we said never again and in
February 24 2020 you had you know 300
000 Russian troops with thousand tanks
and aircraft under the under a nuclear
threat black umbrella blackmail you know
invade a free and Democratic European
nation this is as serious as you can
find now I think it had all the opposite
effects that uh you know Putin wanted
which is NATO coming closer together the
Democrats the Republicans becoming
United uh uh you know Sweden and Finland
hopefully joining the NATO et cetera but
this is still very serious and the other
big effect is it's it's it's affecting
every major relationship in the world
between the Western World the autocratic
World Iran North Korea all of that
including trade investment uh anything
related security so I I think this is a
very serious issue do you think the
world is more dangerous than at any time
in your lifetime yes
I I think it's hard to argue that it's
not you know uh again we haven't had
something like this since World War II
I spoke to Jamie dimon for over 45
minutes on subjects ranging from the
health of the economy and the future
path of interest rates to leadership and
indeed why he says he won't run for
president
subscribers to The Economist can view
the full interview on our app or on our
website and if you're not already a
subscriber you can become one by
clicking the link here
so that turns to the need for leadership
and since World War II the you know the
US has been the global hegemon leader of
the Free World but when you look at the
US now an unbelievably polarized country
the economy is doing well but incredibly
politically polarized country it looks
like we're you know gearing up for
another Trump Biden rematch is U.S
politics capable of that kind of
leadership one of the beautiful things
about democracy is we could argue we can
talk we share information people change
their minds if they don't like their
leadership they change their leadership
I think it's very important to point out
it does need American leadership I don't
mean that as an arrogant American I mean
that there is no one else can provide it
economically militarily it's got to be
done with allies it can't be you know we
can't be our way or the highway when it
comes to every little thing it's going
to be economic diplomacy development
Finance so I would love to see us do
more of those things and and but I think
a lot of the government members do so
really an appetite for that I mean if
you look back at the
report for American engagement for
American Global Leadership now if you
look certainly the Republican Party
there's a growing isolationist Wing in
that party and it's not at all clear
what a future president Donald Trump
might do in terms of American leadership
if you're outside America if you're you
know I live in London
we're worried about this I would worry
about another Trump presidency too by
the way but I think
there's always been an isolation element
it took us it took a lot to get us into
World War One it took you know a lot to
get into World War II but I think if you
go to Washington DC when it comes to
Ukraine it's it's been pretty tight
Republicans and Democrats so when it was
needed it was there and I think the
other thing we have to explain to the
American public is this is we're doing
it for America so of course you have
America First meaning you know can you
imagine someone running for president
saying America second but we're doing
this for America if America gets
isolated you know if if autocratic
Nations kind of cherry pick the world in
security and food and economics and
development Finance you know the Chinese
are all over Latin America which they
are in Africa and we're not there that's
a huge mistake for America so the
America should be doing this for itself
we have to explain to the American
public why it's important I guess the
reason I worry about that is that in
both parties there's been movement away
from that there's a sense that America's
old approach wasn't working so the kind
of the kind of thing that you are
describing
I just don't see as much support for I
think a lot of people are throwing a lot
of stuff in there saying oh American
leadership and the economy and
Enterprise and capitalism it wasn't
working it was working so I I think
that's a huge mistake and somehow we're
confusing National Security with all
these other things like I don't think
it's a smart thing for America to be
going around the world lecturing all
these other countries about stuff I I'm
more in the real politic Camp you know
where these countries have their own
interests we should understand that we
may not like it we may not like
everything they do they don't like
everything we do but I I would focus on
security and and
economic strategy I'd focus on those
things that keep the Western world
together but that does not mean there
aren't flaws we've done a particularly
bad job in America taking care of our
lower paid citizens particularly in
parts of Rural America and the inner
cities that's a fact
we should just acknowledge that what
what do we get wrong like think of inner
city high schools what do we get wrong
when it comes to Health Care got things
right that we have some of the best in
the world Pharma doctors science
hospitals I'm a beneficiary of all that
but we got things wrong too much obesity
too much drugs too much you know we got
things wrong with jobs we got things
wrong we should acknowledge those things
without denigrating my country because
I'm also against that that somebody at
the denigrate America because you know
we made mistakes there is no Nation on
the planet who didn't make some terrible
mistakes let's talk about bidenomics you
know the president has been out touting
bidenomics yet his approval ratings on
the economy are pretty crummy
um do you think bidenomics has been a
success God it's a tough question to
answer look I'm in favor for the first
time in my life of some industrial
policy for security reasons and for
competitive reasons and stuff like that
it shouldn't be political it should be
purely economic or something like that I
think one of the things I think the
American public looks at is is our
government competent effective is it
becoming too much big brother and I
think those are different questions than
the IRA Act and also and also the fiscal
spending five trillion dollars of excess
fiscal spending over two years some to
counter covid but some is far more in
excess that is causing the inflation so
how would dymonomics be different from
biodynamics first of all I'm free
enterprise person I think markets do
work I think we talk about the flaws in
the markets there have always been some
floors in the markets but if that's
being used to get rid of free enterprise
that's a mistake the most important part
of free enterprise isn't capital is
people the movement of people the brain
power of people your ability to start
and think and grow and move and things
like that and so I would have growth
policies you know we we haven't done a
particularly good job in this country to
give you a number we grew in from the
last 20 years something like 1.7 a year
it should have been three percent you
know we should be criticizing ourselves
why wasn't the three percent I
personally believe it's because we've
done a terrible job in Immigration
taxation mortgages affordable housing
health care I think we go three percent
three percent would mean the average
American would have fifteen thousand
dollars more GDP per person this year
that's we should have done that would
have paid for better safety nets that
would be paid for more military it would
have paid for more schooling whatever
you think you know we need to do more of
it but that list of things that you've
laid out it doesn't bear a huge amount
of resemblance to the things that the
administration is focusing on I mean
bidenomics as you said it's it's about
industrial policy it's about a bigger
role for the state
yeah I'd be careful about that you know
and we all agree we needed a better job
in education we should be making it
cheaper not more expensive kids should
know if I graduate this certificate or
this degree I could get a job making 75
000 a year we just do a better job at
that you know we're doing work with the
community colleges in New York to give
kids certificates around cyber data
program management financial management
that gives them a job a livelihood and
then of course jobs lead to dignity
better outcomes better social outcomes
more Mobility I think in our society we
forgot you know we make fun sometimes a
burger flip a job that first job the
first rung in the ladder it matters that
brings dignity you know I would do
things like expand the Earned Income Tax
Credit which is a little form of
industrial policy it's a negative income
tax I think it would help Society
dramatically to get more hands in the
lower paid who would probably spend that
money take care of their families and
their neighborhoods and like I said
better social outcomes so
listen to you I I hear you talking about
this I think that from for a man who
runs runs a very big successful Bank you
have a lot of ideas about public policy
why don't you run for office
I you know I'm 67 years old I think
that's Young by The Standard
presidential candidate I think
I do I don't I've never really believed
I'm suited for it and I also think if
you're going to do that you should
practice you know you don't just say oh
I'm going to run for office you've got
to learn how to run for I think running
there may be common skills between a CEO
in terms of Administration Management
leadership but also non-common ones you
know you're dealing with a whole bunch
of different issues and a bunch of
different venues and stuff like that so
uh you know I think it's perfectly
reasonable people think about it I think
it's very hard to do and in fact if you
just look at history it's almost
impossible you know except for Donald
Trump but he is the exception and that
may be the exception for 100 years but
you know every other American president
spent a lot of time in politics or was a
respected uh General basically
he is the exception remember that was
the third time he ran kind of that's
true what about serving in an
Administration maybe one day that I'll
be in the cards but that's not the cards
right away but I love my country and you
know I might you know to me my family
comes first but my country's right next
you know J.P Morgan's down here jborn is
my best contribution that I can do to
you know like we have 300 000 employees
we take care of them all we give them
opportunity we Bank the World Bank the
IMF we Bank Ukraine we Bank Poland we
Bank City Schools States hospitals I'm
very proud of what we do we help our
employees we help five million small
businesses it's unbelievable that's my
contribution is there ever a tension
between what's good for your country and
what's good for JP movement yeah but I
would always pick what's good for the
country and I think we need I I think
business also I criticize government
sometimes I'd also criticize business
where you know they go to Washington DC
and it's always feeded the trough we
have tax breaks for sugar and cotton why
we have carried interest why you know
people going down there and just
fighting for only I think it's a mistake
if if Business Leaders said we can grow
the economy faster with good policy that
would be far better for their business
than just getting a little tax break
down there I think you said a decade ago
that you were barely a Democrat and I
think in 2019 you said your brain was
probably more Republican but your heart
was Democrat which party are you closer
to I don't know I'm still in the same
place I think we should be taking care
of our our citizens like I said we
haven't done a particularly good job for
the bomb 20 or something like that and
and I want to do a better job I don't
think there's anything wrong with that
but in the in the end you have to put a
tick in a box so I'm not expecting you
to tell me where you put you're taking
the books but which I'll put it this way
which party has changed more and which
part did you worry about its direction
are you making the parties binary
they're not it's like look I'm highly
critical of the parties too sometimes
when I go down to Washington you know I
call them the wing nuts yes they're
there but there are a lot of very smart
people in both parties so I know and
respect that really want to get things
right and you know that I try to focus
on that Jamie Diamond thank you so much
always a pleasure thank you
thanks for watching if you'd like to
read more of our business coverage
please click the link and don't forget
to subscribe